our special worth matters coverage takes
us to one of the most dangerous places
on the planet for air pollution in India
nearly 1.8 million people die every year
as a result of dirty air the World
Health Organization says 9 out of 10
people across the globe live in places
where the air quality is poor before she
went to Sri Lanka Elizabeth Palmer spent
a week in India's capital New Delhi to
see the human toll Delhi is 10 with
tubes in both lungs fighting
tuberculosis a lot of respiratory
distress yeah difficulty in breathing he
still is
and so is every patient in the emergency
ward of Delhi's National Institute for
TB and respiratory diseases all of them
are victims of Delhi's filthy air every
day between eight hundred and a thousand
people with lung problems line up here
to be treated doctor Arvind Kumar is a
prominent chest surgeon and founder of
the lung care foundation we have no non
smoker in India everybody living in
India is a smoker he means just from
breathing the air at its worst it can be
70 times dirtier than the World Health
Organization considers safe in Delhi a
booming city of 19 million a thousand
extra cars hit the road every day
contributing to Merck that's dangerous
in many ways but the real cost of this
pollution is human health so brain
attack brain development poor heart
attack hypertension birth defects
politicians had no choice they had to at
least try to go green if you need a taxi
in New Delhi you get into one of these
but with a hundred thousand rickshaws
spewing pollution into the air the
government had to do something so it
started out by banning the
gasoline-powered ones now the natural
gas ones are being phased out because
the future is electric and it's being
built here at Shi guarantee Volt strips
off factory on day's outskirts not very
high-tech maybe but these vehicles are
zero emission batteries are here Shishir
Agrawal the managing director headed the
shift to electric models three years ago
so the writing's on the wall India is
going electric yes it is inevitably
already the e-rickshaws aren't here
they're cheaper to run they can be
recharged by the driver at home and the
government is about to subsidize the
cost of the batteries that's because
India can't clean up unless everyone
even a forest can afford to join in take
traditional cooking fires in the slums
they send fine particles of burning wood
garbage even dung deep into the lungs
smoke is a huge part of Delhi's air
problem while cooking fires like this
may nourish a family at the same time it
makes everybody's health that much worse
so the government is subsidizing an
alternative clean burning natural gas
stoves at a price almost everyone can
manage air is needed for every breath
the only thing you can do if you want to
avoid total damage is to stop breathing
which unfortunately we cannot do for
more than a minute there is some hope
peak pollution levels in New Delhi seem
to have leveled off so now the urgent
challenges to actually bring
for CBS this morning
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in you dead I mean
that was alarming dear from that doctor
a lot of work yeah look how we complain
here when you see the slightest bit of
smog here stuff we just take for granted
in this country
it shows you what other people are
dealing with my can you think the future
is electric cars everything really
interesting